So normalized cuts fixes this bias
that Ncut has of, wanting to
pull off these little elements.
And the way it does it is it's
going to propose a cut, and
it has the traditional
measure of cutting A and B.
But it's normalized, by the association
within A and the association within B.
And a simple way of thinking about is
the association is just sort of how
well connected,
summed over all of the nodes within a,
in a segment how well
connected those points are.
So the problem is,
is if you have a two segments, and
one is very small,
it's going to have a very small value.
And if that denominator
becomes a small value,
that whole element becomes very large.
So, even though the,
the other element might be a small size,
the fact that this one became
small will penalize that a lot.
So, by doing a this
normalization you can end up
with a much better cut of the graph.
If you just wanted to do,
the best end cut normalized cut that
would be computationally-prohibitive.
But there's an approximate solution
that exists using what is referred to
as the generalized, or solving
the generalized eigenvalue problem.
I'll just show you a very simple,
not simple,
I'll show you a very high level
description of, of what goes on.
And if you want more details,
you can go and take a look at papers or
Wikipedia or anything like that.
And so here, here is how it works.
Let's suppose we've got the matrix W,
which is the adjacency matrix.
So W,i,j is just the adjacency
between pixel i and pixel j.
And then, there's a special matrix,
this diagonal matrix,
that is just what's called
the degree of the node.
For every vertex, how many other
vertexes is, are connected to it, right?
And so in this case, it's the sum, so
the, the, it's a diagonal matrix,
so the, the degree of pixel i
is just the sum of all the affinities
i,j summed over all the j.
And then what you can show
is the normalized cut cost,
can be written in using this,
simple expression,
where this vector y is what's
referred to as an indicator vector.
So it's a vector that's
got positive ones and
negative ones as to whether, remember
cutting this into two parts A and B, so
it's a positive one if that
point belongs to segment A.
And its a negative,
constant otherwise, all right?
So just to solve even that for
y is very difficult, but,
what you can do instead is,
this is just written out here.
We solve this eigenvector equation,
and what that'll do is it'll solve for
you for these y's directly.
But these y's, they're not going to be
binary, you know, minus one or plus one.
They're going to have,
continuous values, and
what you then do is you use that vector
in order to solve for, the partitioning.
And this is related to,
spectral partitioning, for
those of you who are familiar with those
algorithms, and it's just a, an ei,
an eigenvalue way of approximating
the solution to this partitioning,
because the full solution would
computationally too difficult.